ce bonjour de nouveau on attend
maintenant la la conférence de presse du
secrétaire général de l'otan au sol
tanberg à quoi faut-il s'attendre selon
vous
eh bien écoutez le renforcement du flan
s1 devrait être la décision stratégique
la plus l'une des plus significatives de
ce sommet l'alliance devrait notamment
annoncer le déploiement de quatre
nouveaux groupements tactiques dans les
pays voisins de l'ukraine la bulgarie la
hongrie la roumanie et la slovaquie 1 je
vous rappelle que depuis le début de la
guerre en ukraine l'otan a envoyé des
dizaines de milliers de soldats dans
cette zone les dirigeants devraient
aussi s'engager à renforcer les
livraisons d'armes à l'ukraine est
également à fournir des équipements en
cas d'attaqué chimique une hypothèse qui
changerait totalement la nature du
conflit du conflit d'après le secrétaire
général de l'otan et jens stoltenberg
ce matin mais on ne sait toujours pas à
ce jour quelle serait elle la réaction
de l'otan en cas d'attaqué chimique par
ailleurs le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky a pu s'exprimer
devant les dirigeants de l'otan dans une
allocution vidéo il les a appelés à
réagir plus fermement mais vous le savez
l'alliance a repoussé les appels de
l'ukraine à la création d'une zone
d'exclusion aérienne un par crainte
évidemment d'être entraînés dans un
conflit direct avec la russie merci
beaucoup